ومن بين المواقف اللافته خلال الحرب
الاسرائيليه على غزه موقف كولومبيا التي
اعلن رئيسها جوستافو بيترو في الاول من
نوفمبر الماضي استدعاء سفير بلاده لدى
اسرائيل احتجاجا على الحرب كما طلب وزير
الخارجيه الكولومبي الفارو ليفا في منتصف
اكتوبر من السفير الاسرائيلي في بوغوتا
مغادره البلاد وقبل هذا القرار كان الرئيس
الكولومبي شبه الهجمات الاسرائيليه
المتواصله على قطاع غزه باضطهاد النزي
لليهود خلال الحرب العالميه الثانيه معنا
الان من دافوس جوستافو بيترو الرئيس
الكولومبي السيد الرئيس اهلا بك طبعا حتى
موعد هذه المقابله معكم السيد الرئيس وغزه
تحت طائله القصف الاسرائيلي بكل مناطقها
وبشكل كثيف
للغايه تعبيركم عما يجري في غزه ونحن
نتجاوز الثلاثه اشهر على هذه الحرب
والجميع يعلم موقفكم منذ البدايه خصوصا مع
طرد السفير الاسرائيلي من بلادكم واستدعاء
سفير لدى
[موسيقى]
اسرائيل نعم هناك صراع مسلح ما بين حماس
والجيش الاسرا الاسرائيلي لكن ما يحدث في
حقيقه الامر ليس حربا ولكنه اباده واعتقد
ان هذا قرار لمجموعه
من الاطراف في الحكومه الاسرائيليه واعتقد
ان هذا قرار يعود لجزء من المجتمع
الاسرائيلي ويحضر بالدعم ضمن المجتمع
الاسرائيلي من اجل تدمير شعب بشكل كامل
ليس فقط ثقافيا ولكن من خلال التدمير
المستمر خلال القصف المستمر للمدنيين
الذين ليس لديهم مكان يحتمون فيه اذا نحن
راينا تدمير كبير وقتل لالاف من
الاطفال
وايضا القتل للسيدات
ول النساء والابرياء اذا هذه ليست حربا
هذه اباده والاباده هي جريمه جريمه ضد
الانسانيه وجريمه ضد السكان في
غزه
و ايضا هناك الكثير من الشعوب التي
واجهت الاضطهاد
وواجهت الكثير
من مصائر الصعبه الان نرى بان هناك معاناه
للسكان في غزه معاناه
مستمره ولهذا نحن نحيي خطوه جنوب افريقيا
لان جنوب افريقيا تمسكت بقيم الانسانيه
وتمسكت بالقانون الدولي الذي نشا منذ فتره
طويله
واعتقد ان ما قامت به جنوب افريقيا ايضا
يتسق مع المواقف الموجوده في امريكا
اللاتينيه التي تدعو للحريه
والاخوه والمساواه وهذا يتسق ايضا مع
القيم
الديمقراطيه الان نرى بان هذه القيم تنتقل
الى جنوب افريقيا التي اصبحت عاصمه لهذه
القيم بينما كانت باريس قبل قرون عاصمه
لهذه القيم نرى بان جنوب افريقيا تحمل
الان المشعل من اجل
مقاضاه جزء من ال المجتمع الاسرائيلي
والحكومه الاسرائيليه التي تقوم
بهذه الافعال ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني السيد الرئيس ماذا
عن نظرتكم وريتكم للموقف اللاتيني بشكل
عام والى اي مدى يمكن ان يكون هذا الموقف
موحدا ومؤثرا ربما في المرحله
المقبله
في الوقت الراهن
غالبيه الشعوب والدول في امريكا اللاتينيه
طلبت بوقف اطلاق النار وتحدثت عبر منصه
الامم المتحده
وايضا مجلس الامن الكل
والغالبيه في امريكا اللاتينيه هي تدعم حق
الشعب الفلسطيني وتدعو لوقف اطلاق النار
هناك فقط القليله كال الباراجواي اورجواي
جواتيمالا
و هي
صوتت الى جانب دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه واسرائيل اذا
نحن نتحدث هنا عن اقليه كبيره داخل مجلس
او داخل الامم
المتحده ولكن هذه الحكومه صوتت ضد اراده
شعوبها التي خرج ج الى الشارع دعما للشعب
الفلسطيني هذه حقيقه في امريكا اللاتينيه
نحن نريد ان ان
تستمر الخطوه القضائيه التي اقدمت عليها
جنوب افريقيا
وينبغي لهذه المسطره ان تمضي نحو الامام
وهذا يتسق مع الموقف الامريكي
اللاتيني
نحن نتحدث مثلا حول خطوات متقدمه من قبيل
عدم شراء السلاح من اسرائيل وينبغي ان
نؤكد على موضوع السلام واهميه
السلام السيد الرئيس بناء على
تصريحاتكم ومواقفكم مما يجري حاليا في غزه
وحتى اللحظه تصفون ما يجري هناك بالعباده
وليس بالحرب هنا هناك طبعا ردود فعل
اسرائيليه بناء على هذا الموقف اسرائيل
اليوم توقف كل اشكال التعاون العسكري
والامني مع كولومبيا ما هو موقفكم من
ذلك نحن نحن من قال باننا لا نريد طبعا
اسلحه من كوم اعتقد ان هناك
تاريخ طويل في هذا الصدد وهناك احد المز
من اسرائيل كان جزءا من الجيش
وكان مدربا
ل لبعض اعضاء في كولومبيان وهذا تسبب في
الكثير من المعاناه في
كولومبيا والسيد ايتم من الموساد قد قتل
ايضا في
السابق وفي ذلك الوقت كان يحضى بدعم
اليسار يسار في
كولومبيا
و ينبغي ان نتحدث عن هذا الجانب من
التاريخ و
اعتقد انه من ضور جدا ان يتم اتخاذ مواقف
قويه من جانب
اليسار كولومبي واعتقد اننا شاهدنا في
الماضي ايضا صراعا ضد
الناسيه
وصوري هذا تتحدث عن مواقف تغيرت الامور
تتحدث عن مواقف اقوى متوقعه ربما او مامول
من اليسار
الكولومبي السي
الاعتراف بدوله فلسطينيه هل يمكن ان يكون
من ضمن الخطوات الجريئ التي قد تتخذها
كولومبيا
مستقبلا نحن لدينا علاقات دبلوماسيه مع
فلسطين
ونحن نقول بان هناك
فلسطين منذ فتره ولدينا علاقات مع فلسطين
ومع اسرائيل وهناك سفير فلسطيني
في كولومبيا ونود ايضا تعيين سفير كولومبي
في الدفه الغربيه كي تكون لدينا ايضا
سفاره هناك اذا العلاقه وهذا الاعتراف
موجود اذا ليس فقط من قبل حكومه اذا
نحن نتذكر كل تلك الاتفاقيات السابقه في
كم ديفيس وايضا الاتفاقيات الاخرى اذا نحن
ندعم ايضا حل الدولتين دولتان تعيشان جنبا
الى جنب بفضل او على اساس اتفاق سل ونحن
ندعم هذا
الموقف شكرا جزيلا لك الرئيس الكولومبي
جوستافو معنا من دافس